thank you for being a fan  it's being held in chicago in april and  fans are all gathering to celebrate  friendships scandinavian nitwits sexy  southern belles stern substitute  teachers and sicilians i'm guessing  there'll be a little cheesecake that  they can enjoy there too john nether  all of the classic moments oh gosh that  was just it was a great show  i can't get over it  we all identify with one of them do you  is there one that you are like that's my  person i like blanche i think she's so  funny which one was she was she the sexy  southern belle okay that's what i  thought okay yes yeah i think people  would think that about me too  a sexy southern belle you are you are  yeah let's not pursue that any further